- Speaking of running for office,
there's a game on the web right now
to figure out your personal
presidential campaign slogan.
I love it.
It's your name, the year you
want to run for president,
and the last thing you texted.
(audience laughs)
So, I feel like it works.
Mine, and I figured
this out before the show
and it's awesome,
mine is Clarkson 2028,
oh shoot, you actually just reminded me
that Cassie texted me,
and I never got back to her.
I'm such an ass.
Please tell her I'm so sorry,
I just remembered, grimace face.
(laughs)
Its like, that's my slogan. (laughs)
(clapping)
Well, what is yours?
- I brought out my phone.
- I was like, beforehand I was like,
"I cannot believe this is my last text."
(laughs)
- Actually I just, I texted Cab,
because I was actually sending
him the first two episodes,
'cause he gets extra, first.
So I just went, "Just for you, baby."
(laughs loudly)
It'd be like, Dawson
2028, just for you baby.
(audience laughs)
(clapping)
- That's actually awesome!
- It sounds a little bit,
I remember being at the Met Ball
and Rihanna was performing
and then the surprise
guest was Kanye West,
and he came out and everyone
got super excited to see him
and the first thing,
he walks up to the mic
with all this like rounding applause,
and the first thing he
says is, "You're welcome."
- Oh my god.
- And I was like, "You know, he's talking
"about running for office,
"and I think that should
be his campaign slogan."
- [Kelly] You're welcome.
- Kanye West for
president, you're welcome.
- I actually say that a lot myself,
so I can't make fun (laughs) of him.
Usually I'm like, "You're welcome."
But it's usually when I mess up.